well historic and deadly flooding has
parts of the Midwest underwater this
morning thousands of people have been
evacuated in Nebraska and Iowa where
disaster declarations are in place a
combination of heavy rainfall and
snowmelt are contributing to the rising
waters which have forced the closure of
major roadways and interstates flood
watches and warnings are in effect for
at least a dozen states tomorrow morning
Morgan is in Elkhorn Nebraska one of the
communities isolated by the flooding
demarco good morning Nora good morning
to you this entire area was under water
a couple of days ago the Elkhorn River
right here behind me crested at about
five and a half feet above a 1962 record
and it's the first time that it is fast
a major flood stage level water
stretches as far as the eye can see
in Nebraska fills and homes are
completely submerged I was petrified you
know I didn't know what was how fast it
was coming up
homeowners new the Elkhorn River were
shocked by the devastation every piece
of furniture in the cabin is underwater
you know so that's the worst it's ever
been since we've been out here flood
water shut down roads and highways at
one point totally cutting off the town
of Fremont we are trapped I can't get in
or out of Fremont and so planes are
flying in supplies from all over the
National Guard dispatched a choppers
with one and a half ton sandbags
dropping them in high waters to prevent
the flood from spreading officials say
nearly 300 people have been rescued from
flooding across Nebraska alone the
flooding is an aftershock of last week's
bomb cyclone which bombarded the
Northern Plains with blizzard conditions
now rapidly melting snow and rain have
engulfed of the region with water before
and after satellite images show the
magnitude of flooding along the Missouri
which damaged dozens of buildings at
Offutt Air Force Base a third of the
facility is reportedly under water in
Iowa the swollen rivers busted over and
through levees residents of Hornick Iowa
were evacuated before the worst unfolded
they were allowed to return Sunday for a
few hours and assess the damage to their
homes
the emergency manager that's been
in that position for 13 years said he
has never seen anything like it every
single levy was overtopped
water coming in from every direction now
back here in Nebraska many of the rivers
are not expected to go below major flood
stage level until Friday but some of the
rivers are still rising and this area
could get another inch of rain come
tomorrow as for many of the other
communities are the flooding as it
continues to receives communities
downstream in northern Missouri and
Kansas they are now bracing for the
worst
Gale boy last thing they need is more
rain thank you very much DeMarco